does your family watch the show and
think
wait a minute I never did that you know
I didn't I never stole a blender I just
made that up that's not a plot point but
I know that you know what I mean I know
that if I did a show called Conan I
hired actors to play my parents and my
uh all my brothers and sisters I would
be constantly getting calls like what
the what the [ __ ] was that
I know you had
to steal a scrunchie you know you
you know what I mean no totally I mean
we I kind of like really you know
I I there was this big period in my life
where my parents weren't seeing any of
the comedy I was doing I mean I think I
did stand up probably I wouldn't I
wasn't putting anything online I wasn't
doing anything I just kind of did it
silently for for you know almost 10
years just trying to get it you know
where I wanted it to be and and then you
know when the show was coming out and my
stand-up was coming out I kind of told
my parents I was like look this is
really I'm taking from everyone in the
community you know and there's a
writer's room it's not just me you know
and and I think I worked hard to create
enough likeness but also enough distance
between all the individual family
members so I think my parents were kind
of like okay he's doing something
different and they're also really big
fans of Television like my parents watch
everything you know they they like would
know specific bits of yours like they
they my dad loves comedy he'll watch
late night he watches everything on HBO
so he he I think at first maybe had a
little bit of this like why are you
doing this and we had a couple of those
conversations and then very quickly like
the TV fan and him kind of clicked on
and then you know you know he'll watch
the season and now we're at the third
season and he's like oh yeah you really
nailed the tone you know and I'm like oh
cool I'm like talking about tone with my
dad that's like really cool you know so
that's my father has never said to me
you really nailed the tone it's bad
that's what every son knows I'm coming
home
I'm in the east coast just try to muster
it just try to muster it you really
nailed the tone and then something about
ragamuffins um that's what every
Hollywood son would love to hear from
his father you know nailed to tone don't
even get me started on the lighting you
know just really that's where it gets
emotional your show went to the Middle
East and I'm really fascinated by this
because tell me exactly where you shot
season one we shot in Egypt
um and then season three we shot in
Egypt and we shot in Jerusalem right
yeah and so we took my character you
know from the first season we've kind of
seen him he he again he doesn't really
have a passion he gets in his uncle's
family business yes and he's selling
jewelry in the Diamond District which
was based on a couple of my buddies that
I grew up with who were like the three
Lebanese dudes in the district and
everyone else is mainly Jewish and and I
would walk in and just the banter would
be hilarious I mean everyone's just
going at everybody and it's the same
guys everyone's going back and forth
like saying really really
making deals and like the whole thing
what's crazy too is your uncle character
is so anti-semitic yes you know and
obviously to have an anti-semitic
character but also at times he and this
sounds insane but the stuff he's saying
is absolutely crazy but almost
cartoonishly crazy and you're just
saying nope that's okay now that's not
true but you also give him some
Dimension so that there are times where
I almost feel for him do you know what I
mean or where I think okay I see there's
a human being in there which I think is
next to impossible to do yeah I mean I
think I think you know we wanted to kind
of show him in this position where we
have the Rami character and so much of
his thing is like I'm looking at things
in my family I'm looking at things in my
tradition I'm looking at all these
things and I'm figuring out which things
do I want to move forward with you know
what things do I want to be part of my
life so on one hand there's this
spiritual element of it where I think
he's really grasping towards a lot of
these great things that he wants but
then there's a couple of cultural things
and family things that he's like you
know this you know there's certain level
of strictness that's wild and then there
is this like Uncle who walks around with
his anti-Semitism and just watching Rami
kind of bat that away and what that
struggle is is really exciting and and
because I think it's so real and so I
think when people see it they're like I
think it's clear what the intention is
as to why we're showing it uh and how
we're showing it and it exists in every
family I mean there's actually this
really great um show that follows Jewish
Family called Shinto and they have a an
uncle who um sorry and they have an
uncle I love that show oh it's so good
and they have the uncle who hates
Muslims yeah so it's like it it's so
funny because it's like you you see oh
yeah that's and that's another thing
that I've heard from from you know uh my
Jewish friends who watch the show
they're like dude I have that Uncle he
just says it's like it becomes algebraic
you know he just says insert whatever
thing and then you gotta you're trying
to fight that off from that Generation
Well the cross currents of kinds of
um you know racism
is when you see in cultures if you
sometimes you'll I'll be talking to
someone who's from Mexico and they'll
they'll be like oh look at that oh my
gosh from Nicaragua man those people and
you're like what are we doing you're not
even I know you know what I mean you're
and then the next the person Nicaragua
was like just you know keep that
Bolivian away from me most people I
don't know how you do it and you you
know and you realize that this is
happening in China there oh yeah they've
broken it down 75 different ways and oh
that Province well you know can't marry
into that family and you realize that
these this is something uh in our genes
it's everywhere and I've always felt
like it's a little bit unfairly
attributed to being like only white
people you know right because I think
white people are just the best at racism
like I think they like you know
institutionalized it in many ways but
it's right racism we turned it into like
McDonald's we took people like you know
people are like a hamburger and then
white people said no no there's a way to
do this much more efficiently and on a
massive scale just and branded it yeah
exactly but it's not just there's a lot
of organic homegrown racism right in all
of our communities that you know just
isn't branded in the same way but it
really even something like islamophobia
you know we I I've always felt like yeah
there's this idea that people who aren't
Muslim hate Muslims but I've never seen
anyone hate a Muslim more than another
Muslim because they're not the type of
Muslim that they think they should be
like there's like Osama food but then
there's like Muslim islamophobia where
it's literally like just put Indians and
pakistanis in a room and it's just like
man can we find what we have in common
why are we so against each other right
and I think that's a lot of what we have
in the show too is just some of those
elements of again like looking at
something that is a human virus and I
don't want to be in the position where
okay I'm making this show and I need to
show everyone uh Arabs and Muslims are
really lovable and you know don't hate
us because then it just feels so
sanitary and it feels so unreal and it
feels you just kind of don't believe it
so we have a character like my uncle who
exists for that reason just to say we're
putting it all out on the table I mean
when you first introduced him you think
well he's just a joke then you have
these great scenes where you see
um that he has some levels to him which
are really cool you know and so you know
and and it's crazy to say that because
we're talking about you know a a a
character who should just be immediately
canceled but you know that's I think the
thing is you're you're getting really
near these third rails and kind of
touching them a little bit which I think
is important to do yeah it feels like
the most
um I feel like that that's a good way to
put it that third rail or that button
you're not supposed to touch all those
things to me feel like the best thing
that we could contribute as comedians
like to do that as thoughtfully as
possible and to do it in a way where
hopefully we're not just like
spreading the issue uh or or I would say
adding to the problem but yeah that that
feels like the most useful thing I could
do because I don't think any of us are
um you know that well read or
um you know fit to like lead the country
in any sort of Direction but I do think
if we can kind of get into emotional
complexities and and and play with them
a bit that that starts to feel really
fun and and you know we're also just
trying to be funny so I think that that
yeah that's the important thing I think
is it's got to be comedy first yes